um
good evening everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the northwest area
planning committee today on the 3rd of
november my name is councillor maddie
thompson i'm the chairman of this
committee before we commence the
business of the meeting there are a few
housekeeping rules to go through
members we're now working with the set
up for the meeting as agreed at council
on 2nd of september most aspects are
back to the pre-covered normal however
some people will choose to wear a mask
or take other measures and i would ask
you to respect that please
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not speaking
as this is important for the live
streaming to be heard clearly
please a couple of other things please
be aware of the differing levels of the
floor in the chamber and the steps
between them
and the other thing is fire i'm not
expecting a fire drill so if the alarm
does sound we do need to leave by this
door and assemble in the car park at the
front of the building that way
right
members another thing is there is a
members update which was issued a couple
of days ago i think anyway items six and
seven on the agenda there is a members
update so item two is apologies for
absence please
thank you chairman we have received
apologies of absence from councillor
jarvis
thank you
right item three is the minutes of the
previous meeting which was held on the
6th of october
minutes are found on pages 7 to 12
we need to approve them as a true and
accurate record or correct them if not
i so move is there a seconder
thank you councillor white is the winner
does any member wish to amaze and uh
raise a matter of accuracy if so please
just
okay
so can i take those as accepted by a
cent
thank you very much
item four is declaration of interest
another long one to read out i'm afraid
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
required to disclose any such interests
if they become aware
should throughout the meeting
right first of all i have counselor keys
right i've got a non-procurement
interest for 901 i could see the
applicant's father's house from my house
but obviously a lot of houses from my
house
and i've got
987
i've got a pecuniary interest very
slight i'm led to believe but i've not
formally been told i can't say anything
but i'm doing it for the benefit and
i'll be leaving the building for
leaving this chamber for a 9807 and i'll
go home after that if i'm not required
back lucky you not required back thank
you
okay thank you
uh anybody else counselor downrun yeah
thank you chairman and non-pecuniary
interest as a member of essex county
council who has statutory council teas
in the planning process thank you thank
you council fleming
non-pecuniary as a member of essex
county council who are consolities thank
you thank you very much everybody
wonderful thank you
right so we moved to agenda item 5 which
is ivy house hackman's lane pearly
there's no members update on this one
so we just have the presentation please
and then we can move on who's bold
thank you jeff
the plan and permission is sought for
the demolition of the existing dwelling
and erection of a two-story replacement
dwelling with an attached gym and garage
here's the location plan
the site's accessed via a private access
track
which which extends around 300 meters
from hackman's lane to the application
site which is outlined in red here
we have the existing site plan which
shows the existing dwelling and garage
building currently on the site
we've got the proposed block plan
which shows the proposed replacement
dwelling
i've got the existing elevations of the
dwelling currently on site
and the existing roof and floor plans
and the existing garage building
we've got the proposed elevations of the
replacement dwelling
and the proposed floor plans and roof
plan
we've got the existing and proposed
street spoon elevation here
and whilst the built form at the site
has increased
it's not considered to be out of keeping
with the existing dwellings in the
vicinity of the site
then we have some photographs of the
application site and the existing
dwelling
and some photographs of the surrounding
area including the neighbouring
dwelling the proposed replacement
dwelling is significantly larger than
the dwelling which it would replace
however
having regard to the context of the site
and the scale and design of the
existing dwellings within the vicinity
of the site it is considered that on
balance the proposal is acceptable
therefore the proposed replacement
dwelling is recommended for approval
thank you chair
thank you
um members i'm going to now open the
discussion and invite you to put any
questions or make any comments you have
on the report
out of that i hope a proposal will be
made
including planning reasons or conditions
or all of that
if seconded we'll debate that specific
proposal i'd like to close that um we
accept the officer's uh recommendation
and a previous application um
because i called it in because the
parish council had concerns over
sewerage and flooding and but i see that
they've been addressed under a condition
but i want to be certain that there was
a condition added for that and now that
it's added i'm absolutely happy this
application so i only called it in
because i wanted to be certain fine
thank you so proposal to accept
recommendation in the name of council ms
white seconded by councillor keys um can
we have a show of hands please i know i
heard a lot of agrees but
okay that's unanimous everyone thank you
very much that's item five is approved
in line with the opposite
recommendation so we moved to agenda
item six walden cottage 58 walden house
road
we do have
the agent to speak following miss folger
report please
thank you chair so planning permission
is sought for the replacement of the
existing bungalow with a two-story
dwelling and a detached garage and the
extension
to the garden land
um here we've got the location plan
which shows the location of the existing
dwelling
here we've got an existing site plan and
the area hatched right here is the
proposed extension of the garden land
we've got the block plan which shows the
replacement dwelling and garage
and the existing elevation and floor
plans of the bungalow currently on site
the proposed elevations of the
replacement dwelling
and the proposed floor plans
and the proposed garage
as set out in the report there is an
extent
planning permission for
a two-story replacement dwelling at the
site however the design of the
previously approved dwelling was a
traditional house as you can see
which was considered to be in keeping
with the rural area and was of a smaller
scale in terms of width and depth
in addition the
previously
approved application didn't include the
extension of the garden land
we've got photographs of the application
site here
you can see this is the view of the site
from the road
and then we've got photographs of the
area surrounding the site
whilst there is an extent permission for
a two-story dwelling
the increased scale and alterations of
the design of the dwelling are
considered to result in a development
which is dominant bulky and out of
keeping with the rural area in which
it's set
the proposed extension to garden land is
considered to significantly exacerbate
the harm of the proposal and would
result in an unnecessary intrusion into
the open and undeveloped countryside
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal thank you chair thank you
right and mr mckenna
please come forward take a seat
um please use the microphone when you
begin to speak you we're just getting
the timer up you will have exactly two
minutes from when you start to speak so
make yourself comfortable and i am very
very strict you don't get so much as a
nanosecond over the two minutes
so when you're ready thank you
i would start by acknowledging that the
information provided to members in the
offices report is subsequently
substantially incorrect and is therefore
misleading page two of the report for
this application shows the site size as
being twice the size of the application
site
notwithstanding this a substantial part
of the land the council illustrates on
the drawing of page two of the report is
agricultural land not in the applicant's
ownership
still it is a considerable part of the
reason for refusal
the land which forms the application is
purely amenity land therefore this hefty
reason for refusal should be dismissed
the actual application sites uh before
you has existing planning permission for
a four bedroom detached dwelling house
which is extent simply this planning
application is for a four bedroom
detached dwelling house
the only difference between this
application that of the previously
permitted scheme is simply a matter of
design and scale
we believe this site deserves a bespoke
sympathetic and appropriate design that
reflects the quality of the site and the
broader vernacular of great tottenham
the application is carefully designed
and uses high quality materials
the design makes architectural
references to both the existing and
newer houses in walden house road
recently approved homes of similar sizes
on smaller sites exist within 500 metres
of the site
regarding scale the application dwelling
house is only 13 larger than the
currently permitted scheme
this increase is partly due to the
inclusion of a home office which has
never been so important in these
uncertain times of covet 19 and ongoing
sustainability
this increase in scale is offset by
including additional land to the rear of
the property thus offering an increased
house size this land is removed from the
highway
great tottenham is a wash with large
detached housing such as this
application this application's designed
therefore reflects reinforces and
complements the village and wider area
the council's recommendation for refusal
based on the above is therefore
misleading your best
right members that is our only public
speaker so as before open the discussion
invite you to make put questions or make
comments and then hopefully we'll have a
proposal to debate um i've got a whole
bunch of hands up um
council keys did call it in so i'll go
to him first and then i'll do with the
order i spotted you in unless you prefer
to go later
okay i spotted you in the order of
councillor morley councillor white
um yes i'd like to know
what the height difference of the
property
proposed at the moment to the one that
was
originally proposed please
okay
through youtube the height is very
similar i think it's about 0.1 meters
shorter than the previously approved
wedding
thank you
um comes from this wine i think i can't
do that
thank you ma'am sherman i mean i have to
say i i i if it's around about the same
height and it's just a little bit bigger
and it if it is only 30 percent bigger
i've actually got no problem with it and
i'm happy to put forward a proposal we
approve it because i think if we go to
appeal on this one we've we've we've
done a rock and a hard place it already
has permission residential permission i
think to refuse it it's just ridiculous
so i'm happy to put forward a proposal
that we go against the officer's
recommendation and we approve this
application so if i go second or not but
that's my opinion we have got a second
but i'm going to carry on let the
discussion and questions carry on so
counselor darren
thank you can we have the um
that one and the propose please
right and now back to the other one
please
okay well my personal view
i mean a couple of points i mean yes
in respect including a home office we
now have planning guidance that there
should be allowances made for home
working facilities that's absolutely
acceptable
but i i don't think it's
in keeping or sympathetic with the
location to be quite honest um i that
the extent um
the extant
design is
uh and if we can just now go back again
to
the proposed
can we go back to the proposed
i think we're working on it yeah thank
you um i i just think that is
desperately incongruous and um you know
it's not a question of
my personal preference um i won't
express you know that but i just think
in this particular location
that is just not in keeping and i
actually agree with the officer's
recommendation on this thank you
chairman thank you council
uh thank you chairman uh
one question is in terms of the immunity
land my understanding is is that the
land around it is not amenity land
uh it is just agricultural or fields or
grazing land
uh could the officers clarify that for
us because i understand it's not
community land at all
the land to the rear as
demonstrated on this plan here so this
is the additional
garden land they are trying what they're
proposing to change the garden now but
it is currently opened agricultural
land
sports um if we go to the existing
uh replacement drilling which has been
approved
and to the layout of that please
uh the
from what i can see on that design
the room that's on the bottom left
is described as a family room
so could that not be used for home
working
okay so you know already that there is a
space in this in the approved uh
dwelling
i also agree in terms of the office
recommendation the
the the proposed development that's
approved
is within keeping within walden house
road walden house road
is very much the mixed range of houses
but there isn't anything that matches
what's being put forward at this
particular time
that the
the the the larger houses that
you know probably you're about half a
mile away are are on kelvin road so the
the development in terms of what's
proposed and what's there at the moment
and in terms of
yeah the type of properties that walton
house road
exists at the moment
this thing would not fit uh and would be
as councillor durhams
the officers say would be totally
incongruous
with what's um
on that road at the moment
thank you i've got council fleming next
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
miss bowles um just do you have pictures
of the neighboring properties
this one wasn't yeah do you have them
either side at all
yeah through you tear these are the only
pictures i have i don't have any of the
actual properties within the plots
thank you so
um just
through you chairman um just to give me
an idea so is that the sort of
properties either side are they single
story double story or
sort of rough sizes
for you test sorry i don't have that
information
thank you
it's okay
oh sorry counselor
yeah well i can answer that question
have it been brought up with great
autumn um
so right next to the property to the
left is a is a field to the right of the
property is a bungalow which is set back
from the road behind that is a detached
house but not not particularly imposing
or large
opposite this property is is open fields
there is also a small farmhouse opposite
uh set back from the road uh to the
right of that sort of looking away from
the property
is some agricultural buildings and a
barn conversion and again a an
old-fashioned farmhouse if we go to the
other side of the soviet a bit further
we've got the great tottenham primary
school and then moving further up the
road you've got smaller detached houses
and bungalows and things like that there
is nothing that is a large georgian
imposing house
okay
okay
mr lee yes
comment
as i always advise you know members not
to necessarily take what one member says
without validation or anything i just
say looking at google earth i'd have to
agree with what counselor siddal uh
it'll
summarised it as roughly um yeah the
only other thing i want to raise is
obviously the agent made a comment that
the site wasn't being made any larger as
part of the application
but what i want to just quote is
actually a plan that was submitted as
part of the application so this is from
the applicant from the agent and it
states that the original site area was
full 1
485 meters squared the site increase
area which is their wording
is
651.9 meter squared and the post site
area is two thousand one hundred and
thirty six point nine meter squared so
not quite but just under fifty percent
increase in sight area from this
application thank you chairman
councilman
it's not yeah
it's not question of the size it's just
the look of the place to be honest with
you
yeah i
really don't think it's in keeping in
the
area there i'm sorry but
no
it's just it's so imposing it is
thinking um
mr lee correct me if i'm wrong but i
think part of the issue about the
increase of garden size is the increase
of
what we like to call domestic
paraphernalia which is you know washing
iron sheds
goal posts for the kids all that kind of
thing is that
roughly
okay um ryan i think it's back to you
counselor keys
oh yes sorry microphone please yes thank
you all right yeah i've got a couple of
things here 3.21 it says it's dominant
bulking hold out keep in massive house
now just up the road council citadel
just said i think he remembers probably
i don't know the name of the place john
knights the one on the corner build that
big place well i think probably this one
would fit inside it
and that's just up as you look at the
property to the left-hand side
and um opposite that that white
farmhouse we can see across the road
that's having an extension on the side
of it as we speak that's been passed
it has got a bigger footprint but it's
lower it's got no chimney so in fairness
it is a sick well 1.85 meters which to
us six foot virtually lower because it's
got no chimney stack
is a bigger footprint but it's not so
high and thin
holy out keeping jar in addition to the
landscape it says here 5.28 holy out
keeping prominent and jarring addition
to the landscape 200 yard issues to the
right
is a flat roof we've showed no character
whatsoever primary school
which i think is like a people on an
elephant that's horrendous but that's
been past a long while it's a new build
so it's a lot better than the old
bungalow which had critter windows
and um obviously carbon footprint's
terrible
is this it's not overbearing on a
neighbour's office the same but then in
3.21 they're saying the opposite and
5.34
and it's got more parking spaces for
vehicles for off-road parking which i
think all of us that live in the area
know that that school is an absolute
nightmare for drop offs and pick off so
as many cars as we can get off the road
as possible
and with a big house you will have
people coming and see you well even if
you've got a small house so i think this
vehicle space is definitely a bonus to
it with the garage
and
that's all i can say
but i would like to
encounter what's proposed okay uh before
we vote on that with the complete
proposal
you come back yes sorry please do come
back chairman just make a couple of
points on what uh
just said um reading five point three
point four
my understanding is that it says there
is no objection on impact on neighbours
i don't see inconsistency with that i
didn't say in fact i know because it
just said it was overbearing
yeah 5.3.4 is relation to impact on
neighbours that well overbearing is in
relation to the character into the area
so they're two different material
considerations and determination
application
the other point is my you know this
application hasn't particularly raised
any issues in relation to renewable
energies or sustainable development so
the point about a newer dwelling being
more sustainable than the existing one
would be a neutral point as in a
different new dwelling such as the one
that's previously been approved would
still bring the exact same benefits as
this application is so my advice would
be that being neutral material
consideration and determination of this
application as would additional car
parking uh as long as it's in accordance
with policy requirements anything above
that i would advise wouldn't really
shouldn't really be given any way in
determination application because
we couldn't really assess that'll give
you any real value thank you chairman
thank you um right it was councillor
white's proposal but before we vote on
it we do need the reasons for approval
in full addressing all the reasons in
the report for refusal
and any conditions that um specific that
that we wouldn't delegate to the
officers which would be the next thing i
just feel i i'd um use the same
reasons for refusal as the first
application um that's currently valid on
the site the extended permission
and um just that the fact that there's
already residential planning permission
and it's only 13 bigger and it's
actually lower in height than the
existing planning permission that um i
think it's acceptable
i'd like to say i'm surprised mr darrow
hasn't said it counselor darren but if
it was passing the way it was having the
electric charge shock it through a car
okay thank you very much so we have the
proposal everyone clear what the
proposal is and the reasons for it thank
you very much
so those in favor please
oh sorry and conditions delegated to
the offices if no one has anything
specific in mind
actually i
like i don't wonder if you would add
about external lighting because we do
have
we have had very large houses
like that like christmas trees yeah i'm
happy
there's a lot of lights yeah i mean i'm
happy i'll say that
condition in that external lighting has
to be agree in writing should the
application be approved
okay thank you very much right those in
favor of that
please show
two okay that's against
one two three four five six okay that
proposal falls
um so i'm
going to revert
to the officer's recommendation
so
okay um that's as it stands in the
report so could we have a show of hands
on that please i was in favor
okay one two three four six those
against
thank you very much okay that
application is refused in line with the
reasons given in the
offices report thank you very much now
you're actually leaving right now
frustration but
what's doing it for my own is your life
i'm sorry that you're leaving a job
um
yes
sorry i mean obviously speakers from the
previous item
if you'd like to leave please do if you
wish to stay as members of the public oh
sorry yes councillor why could you
you know if you'd like to stay with us
please do
right so moving on we have
i think having bits of paper agenda item
seven so this
this is land adjacent to twenty four
catch portland great totem
um
there is an item
there is
some information on this on the members
update uh we do have a public speaker
which is the agent who will follow the
office of presentation so please
thank you chair uh firstly by away a
verbal members update a unilateral
undertaking has been submitted by the
agent in relation to the rams
contribution however it doesn't appear
associated fee has been received and the
agreement has not been checked by our
legal team to date so still a reason for
refusal
outline planning permission is sought
for one detached dwelling that land
adjacent to 24 catchpolain great totem
the application is to consider the
general principle of development of the
land for a single dwelling only with all
matters reserved for consideration under
a future reserve matters application
should outline planning permission be
granted
here is the location plan
and here is the site plan
the application is effectively a
resubmission of a previous application
which was refused by the council in 2019
and subsequently dismissed that uphill
there have been no amendments to this
current application since the previous
refusal
at appeal the inspector considered that
the site provides an important open
countryside gap in the road and
contributes to a significant break in
the residential development
the inspector concluded that the
domestic domestication of the site an
introduction of built form would
distinctly alter the character and
appearance of the site and erode the
pleasant rural gap in development on the
northern side of catapult lane
here are some photos of the site
that's just um showing looking north at
the site and then the next slide
are the views uh from the uh
oh sorry it's the indic
sorry of this night
yeah sorry just the views from the west
and the east
is the next one hannah sorry
thank you
in conclusion
whilst the lack of a five-year hand
mounted
housing land supply has been taken into
account it is considered that the
benefits of the scheme being the limited
edition of one dwelling would not
outweigh the harm to the open character
and appearance of the area which due to
the urbanization of the site would
detract from the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside therefore the
development is considered to form an
unjustified sprawl of built form on this
currently undeveloped site and the
proposal is recommended for refusal on
this basis thank you thank you uh mr
degree i'd come forward
i know you've heard the rules many times
but i need to go through morton's sake
you have two minutes from when you begin
to speak and
not a moment
when you're ready thank you ma'am chad
the references just made to the
unilateral undertaking a united
undertaking is precisely that it's
submitted unilaterally
um should this have to go to appeal then
it would be a question that we'd have to
seek costs against the authority for not
accepting that united to undertaking so
that the comments there are
inappropriate and unreasonable
the second aspect is this application
does differ from the previous scheme
because it's for single story
development where the previous one was
for a house and the case officer has
mentioned house numerous occasions in
her report however reference to podcast
5.8 5.13 and 6.1 of the statement we
submitted makes it clear this is for a
single story dwelling so fundamental
difference the other fundamental
difference is the housing supply now
your housing supply is actually not that
far short of the five-year supply
of requirements therefore even one
dwelling would make a difference it
would get you closer to that uh that
limit and stop other schemes elsewhere
members whenever you see an application
before you you normally get a mailbag
full of
comments from locals etc you'll see from
the agenda here there is not a single
objection
from any local resident
or from any council tea
this site is a
worthless scrub bit of land with a high
embankment on one side a ditch and a
pump house on the other um and it also
uh
has quite a slope to it it's not capable
of any alternative use it can't be used
for farming purposes it can't be used
even for emerging purposes if there was
such a phrase or use for the site it's
literally sandwiched between the
the bungalow and the pump house
it has no other purpose whatsoever if
you have any
question about the impact that it might
have on the countryside i would really
ask you to go and visit the site and
you'll see the impact would be
non-existent thank you
thank
mr you i think you had some
please chairman thank you in relation to
the point on the unilateral undertaking
uh the planning agency agrees correct
that it is a unilateral indication a
singly signed document provided by the
appellant or the applicant um that
doesn't mean the council has to accept
it the point is there is a reasonable
charge that we
we chart original costs that we charge
for checking of the united undertakings
my knowledge that this hasn't been
received and the unilateral undertaking
has not been checked therefore at the
moment a reasonable reason for refusal
stands on the fact that there is not a
checked and accepted unilateral
undertaking um it's a standard approach
that members will all be very familiar
with from committee reports and also
appeal decisions where inspectors have
not given costs for us for this approach
so i would not be
fearful of such an approach members
secondly in relation to the comment on
scrubland asthma's
the case officer stated in the
presentation inspector previously looked
to this site and had a significantly
different opinion on the value of this
site and as i've
told you all members a hundred times
you're probably very bored of me telling
you the material situation termination
application is a previous appeal
decision and inspectors valued this site
significantly so irrespective of what my
personal opinion is my whole
professional opinion what the agent's
presidential opinion is or anyone else
around this table the inspector has
looked at this site and found it to have
intrinsic value and that is a material
consideration in termination of this
application thank you chairman thank you
i spotted councillor white first then
councillor durham
uh thank you
has there been any consultation with the
environment agency in regards to the
pumping station
or
whoever happens to manage them these
days they keep changing their
names every week and that's my first one
um one was the flood zone where uh flood
zones two and three were there why where
were they where the yellow line was
squealed on the drawing because i wasn't
wasn't sure about that one so to the
south look like the south west of the
site there was like a squiggly line
and the second one is um
that for me is a materially different
application because it is for a bungalow
and we now don't have a five-year
housing land supply um
so i'm sort of in two minds about and
whether it should be approved or refused
um but if we could just have those
answers because no sometimes um if
they're a problem near a pumping station
the environment agency or whoever deals
with them they object
uh through your chair um we have it
there hasn't been um any consultation
we've received so i think we have
consulted them on the pumping station on
this application
sorry
okay
thank you
chairman in relation to the other two
points um
councilor white is correct that you know
the swirly yellow line on a fair phase
is the flood zone one and two um one
thing i'd just like to highlight that
i'm sure members are aware of in
paragraph 5.3.5 is the inspectors
comments about the flood zone or more
importantly the reasoning why this
dwelling is now set back further than
the other properties and as
that explains the inspector actually
raised this as a concern and while there
was acknowledgement that it was one
property further back it was considered
that the strong prevailing pattern of
development here is fairly linear and
that the provision of one dwelling in
that site didn't respect that and that
was part of the
inspector's decision and just in
relation to councillor white's point
about the five-year land span they need
to balance that against the um
provision of a dwelling um
you know i can reread it the appeal site
provides an important open countryside
gap in the road and contributes to a
significant break in the residential
development the site has a predominantly
rural character and appearance and helps
define the edge of the village and it
goes on that isn't talking about palm
from a two-story dwelling it's not
talking about harm from the appearance
of the development it's talking about
the principle of developing on this side
whether it's a one-bedroom property or a
mansion you know the inspectors found
that actually this site is really
important for being the end of the
village and allowing any formal
development whether it's a single story
development or a two-story development
is what the inspectors found conflict
with and that's really important i think
for members and you know as we've seen
on numerous appeal decisions over the
last 18 months
one two three four bedroom uh
appeals for one two three four dwellings
are being given minimal weight for
solving the five-year land supply so
while every dwelling is a step towards a
five-year land supply you know the
weight that it can be given in the
balancing process has to be how
significant he jumps you know that's the
concern with the schemes for 200 hours
is because inspectors give a lot of
weight to them because it's a big jump
but you know so for that reason i'll
just be highlighting members to all the
previous appeal decisions that say one
dwelling is minimal way thank you
chairman
right not counsellor durham then i think
councillor morley yes and cancer thank
you council
all right thank you chairman i'd like to
make a couple of points
firstly um
nothing rolls me more than being
threatened
um and that goes down extremely badly
uh in my books um
and as mr leo said i i think the the
inspectors comments about the value of
this piece of land
are absolutely valid whether it be
single story or
double story or or whatever um you know
he made it very clear
that this was not a uh i think a useless
piece of scrub land as it was explained
to us
um and the other matter as much as it
pains me to say
i wish we were only a a small
distance away from our five-year land
supply we we are nowhere near it and one
house isn't going to make a job of
difference
and i i just think that the reasons for
um
are are quite sound and are tested at
appeal and i think if this goes to
appeal
uh
we would have exactly the same result
for those reasons thank you chairman
councilman morley and council
thank you chairman through you um
blood zoned i'd imagine that's for
obviously not water but we live near one
of these and when they go wrong they're
pretty nasty
um power cuts
so is it the flood zone excuse me from
the sewage i take it and i'd imagine
that bit of wasteland is to allow for a
little bit of
leeway so when they do flood and i know
they flood
no good saying they don't they they rely
on electric motors
um is that what really the flooding
is
is about please thank you i think it
depends on whether we're talking about
plural pluvial or fluvial
the
chairman we don't have the answer off
the cuffs no really nasty stuff that's
what i mean
i'm getting the message that counselor
siddal can help you with that since he's
next anyway
thank you chairman
so the flooding if you notice to the
left of the site is catchpal brook
the catapult brook is although it's a
small brook it is uh prone to flooding
in that particular area uh i was brought
up on the road opposite this particular
site so i know i've known it for a long
time and i played that book when i was a
child
and the the issue about it is at that
particular point it goes under the road
so it immediately causes a pinch point
for the brook and therefore that
particular fuel can flood
in terms of this particular
site it does give a really nice piece of
open countryside at the edge of the
village
if the site if the proposed dwelling
was in line with the other houses then
perhaps
that would be more favorable but it
can't be in line with the other houses
because of the flooding so really this
this site although yeah you can see oh
yeah this this could be utilized and it
it perhaps it's not used for much at the
moment however on balance because of the
problems with the site it really isn't
suitable for it for a development in my
view
um yeah
we need to to create create good street
seats
in our villages and this would not
create a good street seat and it would
also be really imposing on the property
next door because of its its location
in terms of objections there has been an
objection it was part of the update and
there's been an objection from the
parish council and they are against this
particular application so there is an
objection to this from the parish
council
so
i can see
that yes there's there could be a
benefit to having this developed but in
terms of the problems and the issues
that it is completely outweighed then it
wouldn't be built in a suitable location
thank you
um
council ms white did we have a i almost
have a proposal
i don't think there's much point in me
making a proposal
um i could i could make it i don't know
i'll get a second though but i'll make
the approach that we approve the
application because um i think that
because we don't have a five-year land
supply the
balance should be
in favor of
that i yeah this application because we
do not have a five year amount where the
balance should be tilted in favor of
um development i believe that on the
interview this isn't on page the 19th
the benefit of sustainable location
overcomes the harm of
um the building in terms of the location
i think it makes logical stop to the
existing um development
and around the rams payment can easily
be conditioned
what would suggest is that it would be
delegated to
officers to ensure that the uu was
acceptable and as with the standard one
thank you
okay is there a second
okay i'm afraid that falls so moving on
um
okay we have a proposal in the name
council of durham to accept the
officer's recommendation as is
seconded by council of seattle those in
flow and for flavor
pause up please like comment
share
please
okay uh that proposal is passed so the
um the application is
oh dear i'm sorry is refused in line
with the office's recommendation um
and we're moving on
what's the message with this we'll have
to have a word about this um
other items of business the chairman of
the sides are urgent you'll be delighted
to hear there are none any um
meeting members and officers thank you
all for your contributions this evening
i draw the meeting to a close at that
box says 8 20. it'll do
uh members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion
and please leave the meeting by the exit
door behind the top table
thank you